apple is working on a brand new Macbook
one that's going to be cheaper than any
other MacBook has been before and they
are expecting it to be a really amazing
seller so in this video I give you guys
all the info that we know what we expect
this thing to cost when it's going to be
coming out and why in the world are they
doing this now the first leaks about
this new Mac came all the way back in
February from a mysterious account that
had a mixed track record and because of
that not very many people took it
seriously now this was from a Taiwanese
blog post saying that apple is going to
reintroduce the 12in MacBook but this
time with apple silicon now I have been
wanting this for a long time because I
owned one of those beautiful thin
MacBooks for for about a year and a half
and I absolutely loved it at least most
of it the machine was insanely thin and
it only weighed 2 lb where the current
MacBook Air at the time was about 3.2 lb
and that difference was massive now this
Mac was where Apple introduced a bunch
of new technology they had their layered
battery to make the most use of that
small case that is where they introduc
uced the trackpad that we all absolutely
love the best in the world now and that
machine also introduced the USB type-c
port in first in a Mac and that one was
the only USB type-c port which was
terrible that was probably the worst
thing about it and with it that is where
we got the cursed butterfly keyboard
because they wanted to make this machine
so thin but I absolutely loved it and
the reason why I got rid of of it was
because of the Intel processor it was so
thin and it was the first fanless
MacBook as well and because of the Intel
processor it just overheated like mad
and the performance dropped making it so
slow but now with apple silicon we've
had many fless MacBooks and this machine
could perform way better get better
battery life and actually work really
well and thankfully this time around
it's going to cost $700
or less now back then both M quo and
Ross young were skeptical about Apple
releasing a Mac like this but in that
original leak it said that apple is
still working on the production but they
haven't confirmed if they are going to
actually make it well here we are and
now we have more info that apple is
making a cheaper MacBook and the point
is to be able to compete with
Chromebooks and with cheaper Windows lap
laptops if we take a look at Amazon's
bestseller list for computers we have
the MacBook Air M1 at number one then we
have a Windows laptop then the M2
MacBook Air and then another cheap
Windows laptop along with Chromebook so
this whole list is filled up with
expensive Macs and then cheap
alternative computers now Apple has
never been in the game to make cheap
devices they've been in the higher end
luxury premium kind of lineup so why
would they want to do this well if we
look at this in
2029 Apple shipped nearly 29 million Max
and that was actually the peak of their
sales but in the same year there were
37.3 million Chromebooks that were
shipped out that is absolutely insane
the amount of volume with these budget
friendly machines and a lot of people
want to just get a laptop that could do
some email some web browsing some basic
tasks and not break the bank now with
that Apple sales have been plummeting
even the brand new 15-in Macbook Air
that was priced lower than we expected
had way worse sales than Apple thought
with shipments being 50% less than
originally estimated because the whole
notebook Market has been taking a
downturn everything is getting a lot
more expensive people have less money to
spend so they are not buying and looking
at the whole Market Apple's Mac
shipments fell more than 40% worse than
the rest of the competitors and that of
course is probably because all of theirs
are very expensive compared to all those
budget options we saw and now muko
agrees with this with info saying that
Apple could be targeting 8 to 10 million
units shipped per year that is a lot of
budget MacBooks so when will this thing
come out well the info that we have
shows the second half of 2024 so that
could be right before students go back
to school which would be perfect and
some other info is showing late 2024 so
right around that time frame so we still
have to wait a little while but it is
not years out like when we usually get
leaks and rumors now with that we have
that $700 price tag that is because
higher performance Chromebooks run at
about that price and of course even
though this going to be cheaper it's not
going to be a lowquality product based
on the original info there will be some
differences to achieve this lower price
but with that said it will still be made
out of aluminum on the outside there
might be some changes or some material
changes I don't know if there's a
cheaper version they can make but it's
still going to be nice and premium and A
step above the other offerings now the
weird thing is that there's info on two
different sizes coming out and that is
consistent with supply chain now in this
leak we have a 12 and a 13in model um so
that's fairly close in size there are
some differences uh but with that maybe
one thing Apple could do is drop the M1
MacBook a which is now at $9.99 and now
you can actually buy for a lot less
expensive and then offer a new model
that is cheaper and then a smaller 12-in
which does work really well for some
people especially for classrooms nice
and compact now we have no idea what the
specs are going to be like but based on
new info we have the M3 series of
MacBooks are going to be coming with 12
gigs of RAM this is consistent with the
M2 Maxes coming up to 48 gigs um so
everything's kind of getting a bump
finally from the 8 gig base but if Apple
ends up using say an M1 chip in this or
maybe an iPhone phone based chip they
could easily stick to 8 gigs as a base
um just to get that price down on that
one and to make a kind of a bigger
difference between the cheaper models
and then the more expensive ones and
with that as long as it has one USB
type-c port plus a Max safe charging
port that will be just fine for those
machines a single USBC Port was a pain
previously but just adding a charging
port that actually makes it way more
usable and it will be more than fast
enough um for most people that need
something basic to just do web- based
tasks now you guys let me know would you
be interested in a $700 MacBook um
that's a little bit cut down or would
you rather spend the extra money go
ahead and click that Circle above to
subscribe check out one of those great
videos right over there this been Max
and I'll see you in the next
[Music]
one